about to roll up at the second Spanish
contender fighting for the last place in
the semi-final
the pioneering el parotid de tempest or
the pirate in London's hip Notting Hill
is managed by Roberto and the kitchen
run by Madrid boy Omar it's only been on
for two years already
it's got rave reviews this young Spanish
chef is only 26 and this guy really does
have talent all out how are you
hey well it just to see your Ord thank
you so happy to be here small restaurant
small kitchen big fashion
big fashion show that on every plate of
course HF Omar has a hugely impressive
CV having worked for the celebrated
molecular gastronome Baron Adrian of El
Bulli in Spain voted one of the best
restaurants in the world it was a
tremendous experience for me that has
influenced the rest of my cooking and
the rest of my career
this young bartender has an ultra modern
approach to tappers and uses molecular
cooking techniques to take Spanish
cuisine
into the 21st century with huge style I
like beautiful things in life as we all
do so I think it is great when you are
sitting down in your table and something
beautiful comes into it even though you
don't expect it Omar's experimental
methods can turn a traditional dish on
his head like his jelly dispatcher
straight clever he's got this nice
chilled jelly tasting exactly the same
but I complete different texture yeah in
his mission to stand out Omar bravely
embrace his daring ingredients like he's
confident on the head of the cockerel
which most British butchers throw away
they have truly given to us for free
running their tank because no one's
ordering them no I don't think there's
many chefs anywhere in the country that
has free ingredients that can be clever
enough to charge money for smiles
this competition has just gone up a
notch on the back of the Antonio
Banderas are cooking no bastard far too
good-looking to be a chef
vamos vamos vamos his passion guts got a
huge pair of cojones so this
Omar will need balls up still tonight
he's got just two hours to serve all 30
of my discerning diners and stake his
claim to be the most avant-garde Spanish
chef in Britain
okay just under five minutes my diners
were here thirty of them
those dishes you cooked me earlier more
like little miniature works of art so
make sure my daughters have the exact
same experience good luck
let's do it